but after with emotional problems i find
this hard to believe what the [ __ ] keep
going I am acting here and this [ __ ]
wanders onto my set I don't even get a
line out until don't be the dick starts
whispering in your ear you're not even
watching anymore Dennis Dennis don't
[ __ ] Dennis me I am doing my job here
I am a pro this is the most
unprofessional cent I have ever been on
this is horseshit I've got these [ __ ]
zombies over here that I have to look at
I have a bunch of [ __ ] staring at me
and this [ __ ] baby [ __ ] is garbage
whoa be all right so the baby the
zombies that is by far Dennis Quaid's
best acting performance ever now there's
a rumor i should say right up top there
is a rumor that maybe it was staged we
have no reason to believe that though
but somebody was saying that maybe jimmy
kimmel made this thing happen anyway if
it wasn't staged that's his best working
oscar-worthy Oscar ready what I'm
curious about is who qualifies as baby
who qualifies as [ __ ] and we call about
the zombie like I want to know who falls
into which category yeah cuz there only
seems to be one baby some like there's
only one baby but there are multiple
[ __ ] and multiple zombies I'm like I
won't know what don't be an addictive oh
so you don't think way too baby so yeah
I thought there was actually a baby like
that baby baby but the baby didn't make
any noise if anybody he was the biggest
baby there so yea what did he think was
a baby that's a big I just wanted to
know yeah that's an important question
what do you think of when they leaked
these things like we've seen this before
with plenty of actors having these
mental breakdowns do you think it's like
specific to actors or they could catch
any of us one day having these like
crazy meltdown and that's the thing i
feel kind of bad for him if it is real i
feel bad just because like everyone has
that moment where they break down and
that's the worst version of you in the
worst possible situation when you're
really frustrated and I wouldn't want
that to be like
shirt and put on the internet and
representative of me yeah I hear you
there is something those special about
actors like the way he was yelling like
it's all about me this is what I'm doing
you're staring like he's angry that
people are staring at him but what are
they supposed to do on a set I hear you
and I take your point I think you're
right but to something it is the worst
time to catch them but at the same time
it's like what we do and i classify
myself as an actor because that's how I
make my money you're welcome um but
we've got mics on so like where we're at
we were performing yeah and for me it's
still where you have to there's some
amount of humility that you have to have
with everything yeah with everything
that you do and I think that it gets it
can get to a point sometimes where you
forget that you're not curing cancer you
ain't you ain't solving world hunger
right now or the energy crisis or you
know fixing global warming you just
Ekans so calm your tits so is that
because I apologies but the tits was not
calm yo tits I say that every day I know
um so is that it like actors there's
like this self-importance with them
right like they have to get into
character so I can understand that at
some level but they're not actually
nuclear scientists they're not actually
curing cancer people always like they're
such geniuses but I'm not doing the real
thing they're just pretending I think
about like road rage for a second people
get so angry when they're driving when
someone cuts them off its gonna delay
them like a second to get to where
they're going but it's just you know
sometimes you're just in that really
pissed off moment and someone gets to
you and actors especially like it takes
a lot to get into character sometimes
and to put yourself into that role so
whenever somebody breaks your
concentration over and over again I can
see how that would be very for like I of
course he should be humble and shouldn't
act like a child and stomp his feet I'm
he's been good of an actress only it
made me crazy I just had a bad for him
that that is his like image now yeah
have you guys ever been caught on camera
doing something that you shouldn't been
doing or not real I like had a hot mic
or anything like that yeah it's all
youtube.com slash hey yo Shanna you're
welcome it's every day yeah no not
really
nothing i mean i don't think that bad
about me my youtube channel every camera
in your house everything i say is on
purpose yeah i did happen to me one time
at my old studio they they left the mic
on i didn't realize that a zillion
people were suddenly tweeting at me
asking me why I was talking about high
school and this guy that I hated I'd
like to publicly apologize to keep from
Syosset you're not that terrible a
Republican presidential candidate that's
kind of sort of maybe okay with gays
let's talk about a social or shoot gay
marriage in New Hampshire you said I
will fight for your right to be left
alone I realized that you believe gay
marriage is a state issue but why do you
believe just as a core principle as a
libertarian that people should be left
alone but not when it comes to their
right to marry somebody they love I do
believe people ought to be left alone I
don't care who you are what you do at
home or who your friends are what you
know where you hang out what kind of
music you listen to what you do in your
home's your own business that's always
been a miami leave me alone kind of guy
oh but not when it comes to marriage
well no I mean state states will end up
making the decisions on these things I
think that there's a religious
connotation to marriage I believe in the
traditional religious connotation to
this but also believe people ought to be
treated fairly under the wall I see no
reason why if the marriage contract
conveys certain things that if if you if
you want to marry another woman that you
can do that and have a contract but the
thing is is the religious connotation of
marriage that has been going on for
thousands of years I still want to
preserve that you probably could have
both you could have both traditional
marriage which I believe in and then you
could also have the neutrality of the
law that allows people to have contracts
with another all right I know I'm going
to get a lot of [ __ ] for this but I
basically think that's okay he's saying
gay people should have the exact same
rights but the word marriage has a
religious connotation it's not that I
agree with the principal and I don't
believe in separate but equal but for a
Republican that's trying to win with the
right wing nuts of his party to win a
nomination he's basically saying I don't
care about the gay issue let's not make
it an issue for 2016 I don't think he's
fighting against gay people I get it I
know what everyone's going to say
this I'm gonna go to you first because I
saw that face during the video I mean I
just I don't like it even watching that
made me cringe a little bit cuz its
slimy I get it it's slimy right he's
playing haunted but I know that you're
saying that you know it'll help him win
on the Republican ticket but he's
already said so many things that have
kind of screwed his chances for that
anyways I mean he's very for legalizing
drugs and he's against military
industrial complex over using it and
things like that that I like about him
are you like I like it winslet but I
mean that kind of screws him on the
right but as far as this it's just it is
separate but equal and it's horrible and
he keeps going on and on about how it's
got this religious connotation which is
total [ __ ] [ __ ] because marriage
was going on way before religion came
and stole they don't have a copyright on
it they haven't patent it it's something
that everyone should be able to have and
I think a lot of people who are gay who
get married are actually still religious
I'm gay and going to get married so if I
say this with all due irony still like
ya if there's freedom of religion and
there should be freedom of religion for
people who are gay who want to get
married in a church if they want if
there's a church that's willing and they
want to have it and they think that
that's traditional marriage and that's
what it means to them then why not right
well I don't think he's saying that they
wouldn't be allowed to get married in a
church if the church allowed it I think
he's just saying he just saying the word
and then give gay people just good right
gay people can't have that word yeah the
only reason I'm okay with this is just
cuz I know how nut either the right side
of his party is and he's trying to me
because he's not trying to make gay an
issue he knows that it's done he's a
libertarian he doesn't want to be in
your bedroom so actually he should be
totally for gays and he should be
totally for weed which he's not totally
for that's that's another topic but like
to me that seems like this is progress
like this is progress come on give me
something here what's she saying yeah
like um I have a historical difficulty
with any concept of separate but equal
yeah any concept of it not really i
don't know if it's maybe the color of my
skin little uncomfortable with that
concept in general yeah and the last
time any woman in my family was in a
relationship with a man or with anybody
a woman that there was a contract it was
a slave yeah so really not not down with
that terminology either so does this
year why politics
so [ __ ] up like I'm trying to be like
pragmatic here and being like oh I get
what he has to do politically to do this
but the principle is okay but doesn't
that doesn't this whole thing then feel
slimy because then it's like look if he
doesn't get the support then it could be
a guy like Ted Cruz who would gladly get
rid of gay marriage yeah I'm so sick of
the entire gops discriminate the
discrimination against LGBT people
against women and I really hope that the
left uses that against them in the
upcoming election yeah I mean it's been
50 years since the civil rights era and
there are still people out there who
think that discrimination is okay yeah
it's like if you can't grasp the simple
concept that hey gay people are normal
equal individuals if you can't
understand that then I don't really
think that you can really give much
insight into more complicated issues
it's like hey they think discrimination
is cool now let's see what they have to
say on macroeconomic well exactly
because also it doesn't there's no
logical stand on it they don't you know
and they always say well it'll ruin the
family except we keep getting gay
marriage in more and more states are
have you noticed any families crumbling
actually I've seen families get stronger
I've seen some crumbling you see the
couple something cuz I was really
attracted to this guy turns out he was
gay married another guy and that's see
that could have been a family he ruined
it he ruined that non-existent family
has your family been ruined like
Shauna's by gays these activists gays
let us know what you think in the
comments right down below guys you're
not going to believe this but people are
outraged that something a celebrity did
gwenyth paltrow is challenging herself
to live on twenty nine dollars a week
roughly the same amount each member of
low income families on the Supplemental
Nutrition Assistance Program are
allotted what seems like noble
intentions are being met with I roles
and mockery on social media after
posting a photo of her grocery haul
notorious for being rich in oblivious
Paltrow is being torn a new one on
social media for supposing a diet of
fresh veggies black beans and brown rice
is sufficient enough for hardworking
physically active people mother Jones is
criticizing the actress by title
recent article 1 of the pouch Oh
confuses her latest Master Cleanse with
an attempt to relate to the pork
notorious for being rich in oblivious i
think we editorialized that just a tiny
bit there but point taken now of course
we talked about this whole time outraged
everyone's outraged all the time I'm
outraged about everything constantly I'm
always looking for things to be outraged
by this seems to be one of those cases
where I think she's generally trying to
put good into the world and she they
love knocking her because she's pretty
and she's smart and whatever what she
said she steamed her vagina and she's
rich but she's the one that steamed or
vagina right didn't she steamer vagina
somebody somebody steamed yes a steaming
of a vagina she steamed a vagina will do
it we [ __ ] like a post it's like a
poetry vagina but you take it off a
little early got it um but look I it
seems he's trying to do something good
here and by showing how hard is for
people to live on snap and by the way 28
bucks for a week how is that even
remotely considered but what do you
first let's just over by the outrage
what do you think about all the people
that then just attack people are looking
for something to yell about because one
of the last time any of those
[ __ ] talked about snap ya ever
in life when was the last time the any
of these entitled [ __ ] who weren't
living on twenty-eight dollars or twenty
nine dollars a week yeah ever talked
about it use their social media platform
and their voices to actually bring
awareness to the fact that it's too
little money and people can't get good
nutrition on it where is she she may be
a little bit idealistic I'm out yeah
okay they need a little bit mo rice and
something to keep them feeling full from
passing out yes you can pass out because
you have a bunch of assistance to catch
you but you know I get I get that it's
not maybe the ideal but look at the
intention sometimes I don't focus on the
execution yeah what is that about the
obsession to ignore the intention which
is obviously good if she wanted
publicity she could have done a
gajillion other things beyond trying to
bring attention to snap which most
people don't care about exactly what you
said I mean people just want to be
outraged about something so they're
gonna look past your intentions and see
the food that she bought and say oh look
this is the master cleanse this isn't
food this isn't carbs people who are
low-income around working you know
strenuous jobs and stuff and they need
more energy and carbs to you know
produce that energy and a bunch of leafy
vegetables of garlic and
don't eggs whatever she had isn't
exactly enough substance for most people
but I mean its overall like you said
she's doing a good thing she's trying to
reach out and spread awareness about
something that she thought was important
and instead of like looking at that and
being like ok you know maybe you didn't
do the best job but I see what you're
trying to do i hear you let's just focus
on the problem and you know help here's
a link to donate to people if you want
it you know help them out instead of
focusing so much on what she's doing
wrong why don't you focus on the problem
that she's actually trying to solve so
getting over the outrage portion of this
thing 29 bucks a week my math isn't
great but 29 / 7 days a week is a
foreign change is there any way you
could possibly survive on four dollars
and change a day over the course of a
week not very easily and there's another
aspect to what what took when it's
shopping lists to witches maybe it kind
of maybe would have inspired if they're
on Twitter I mean they probably work in
a job let's give you real people on
snapped ain't got time to be the
hustling so maybe maybe that they didn't
get the message but maybe all of this
talk about it will make them think they
could buy more vegetables and let's crap
even though truthfully speaking it's
harder to eat healthy yeah a smaller
budget than it is to eat a bunch of crap
yeah you know people always say that and
I've gotten [ __ ] for this before but
sometimes it seems to me you could if
you went to trader joe's obviously not a
particularly high n thing I get it's not
everywhere but you could get a thing of
eggs and some peanut butter and beans
about but nobody wants to live like that
nobody wants to look like that number
one my point is that happy meal at
McDonald's whatever it's called is a lot
more expensive than actually like you
could get maybe four of those for 28
bucks when you can actually get some
better ingredients for cheaper it's
still a challenge I mean 28 if you
really think about what when I go into
the grocery store just to pick up a
couple things yeah I spent thirty
dollars I go in fro and I get like three
things that's but I because i want to
buy organic eggs and that you know all
of the things that are better for you
and aren't necessarily as genetic
genetically modified or ask you know no
means it's like even as janelle out of
line knowing it pretty much everything
everything is gonna kill you so this
can be slower yes what yeah but it's
it's just it's this the program is
severely underfunded clearly because
people at anything this is what I hope
this is for one person not for a family
right no this is for a family of four
for a family of because what she had was
just for herself a bunch of like leafy
vegetables and stuff and like that would
be enough for most individuals much less
their family and their right but they
should be more angry that they're asking
for people to survive on that so is that
so is that the crunchiness anger should
have been channeled right so is that the
crux is that the system sort of can't
get fixed because even though now so we
you know the media calls a little bit
tension to this people go all right 28
bucks clearly not enough for one person
much less for people but those people on
the bottom they don't vote as much as
the people up top they don't have access
to voting all that stuff it's a whole
other topic but so there's never the
system never has an incentive to fix the
problem so is that really the problem
here it's not about the what you can buy
with the money right yeah I mean
definitely we need to do different
things to fix the problem a lot people
like to focus on the external issues and
just the media hype of it but I mean
it's obviously a real problem PS i don't
understand how one person could survive
off that much less a family sorry and
when the rage should have been channeled
into getting that program fixed as
opposed to a chronic paltrow who's just
shedding light on something maybe like
minded but still she's doing she's still
doing something more than you are right
yelling at her Wow all right well there
you go to Gwyneth you know everyone's
hating on you all the time but we are
all down with what you're doing anyway
what do you guys think could you
possibly survive on twenty eight dollars
a week just for yourself much less for a
family of four let us know in the
comments right down below 2016 election
madness has begun may God have mercy on
all our souls a bloomberg national poll
shows
d eight percent of republicans and
independents would consider supporting
senator rand paul and the GOP primaries
brand who announced his presidential bid
last week is the current forerunner of
the republican party at least fifty
percent of the same voters who praised
reigns express interest in supporting
five other aspiring candidates including
Mike Huckabee Rick Perry and Mark Rubio
signaling a potentially lengthy
nomination battle alright so we just did
a previous segment where I was defending
Rand Paul a little bit it sounds like
he's in the front at the moment but when
you hear all this stuff and you watch
those names Huckabee like doesn't it all
it seems like a time warp doesn't it
seem like these guys all existing the
time work Marco Rubio he's younger
Latino people seem to dig them but the
rest of them it just seems like
dinosaurs being dug out from Republican
graves yeah and it also speaks to the
fact that I think I mentioned in an
earlier segment that being a politician
is not about your principles or what you
stand for it really are least not a
successful one right being a successful
is a likeability thing its people liking
you and the fact is there isn't a really
strong Republican candidate right now
that's likable they're not likable so
that's where that's why you're seeing
all of this kind of fracturing within
the party of maybe this guy or I could
vote for this guy or this guy or this
guy yeah none of them really embody all
of the characteristics and I think
voters want to want they want to believe
oh this guy can take us and do something
different or this person can do
something different for us and they're
like so we sort of what Jesus right like
that's what we seem to really want is
this like when Obama ran the first time
it was like he was everything everyone
thought he was unbelievable I know yeah
I know sporty sign presented but like it
felt like there was this incredible
feeling like this is the the second
coming and we won't yes we can hope and
change but do we not really need that do
we actually need someone that maybe
isn't likable but actually wants to
hardcore govern and know his [ __ ] inside
out and all that yeah I highly doubt
that the American would public would
ever vote for somebody they didn't like
I feel like that's at the forefront of
everyone's mind like oh they cool yeah
you know like the Republicans can I have
a beer with them if they can then cool
then they're gonna vocal so then is that
why this
country is totally screwed that we get
more obsessed like this week with
Hillary having chipotle and did you see
the video there were literally like
dozens of reporters chasing her into
chipotle and everybody was doing
articles on what did she order it was a
chicken ball like that actually is more
important than what her views on foreign
policy or whatever exactly I think that
it my answer your question because right
way yeah yeah that's a problem and it's
also the problem that a lot of people
especially our young the younger
generation don't actively take a role in
yes making sure that the direction that
the government is shaped in cuz now it's
it's like the entertainment interest
rates industry it's a bunch of 60 and 70
year old dudes all you know jack and
their dicks and saying how great they
are and it's the same ideas that kid
gets certain getting circulated is this
like the sort of catch-22 of social
media also that like I love how it
connects everybody and people know more
and if there's a revolution in Egypt we
can know about it and then at the same
token like our politicians all feel like
they have to be on snapchat and
Instagram and doing all the right things
and it just makes it that much faker
yeah it does seem very superficial but
to not utilize social media would be
very stupid yeah you know and I feel
like it's important in making change and
spreading awareness you know etc how
much how much can you guys talk about
polls before like we're 22 months out
and I know the media is going crazy I'm
in that world my Twitter stream just in
this week because a Rubio and Rand and
and Hillary like I see it already
changing we're already talking about two
years in the future instead of talking
about now which I think it's that's kind
of dangerous don't you think that we
stop focusing on there's still two years
of this guy and and two years of things
that are happening now yes but at the
same time that's it's the it's the
problem and the benefit of living in
kind of an instantaneous instant coffee
type world where you know this news
comes in and it's all your attention
goes on to that full throttle for the
entire day and a half oh my god my
attention and I'm now over here so it's
it's reflective of that world and
everybody wants to explode things out
and new stories because there's so many
sources for news yeah they have to make
things into news that's why chipotle
yeah yeah
why am I watching this I don't even know
why I care yeah cuz it doesn't really
matter in the grand scheme of things but
i think it's it's the way we consume
information now so it's just reflective
of that but i do think you can always
find something that is oh this is the
flaw with this and the flaw with that i
think at the end of the day people just
have to like you said stop looking so
much on how pretty or how cool or how
down-to-earth the person seems and think
about their policies and how that will
affect not only you personally but the
people you care about and the thing the
policies that you care about in your
country otherwise you're [ __ ] i'll try
to spin this positive is something good
actually happening here where we're
getting these nonsensical chipotle
things and you know they said Rand Paul
fights with women because he had one
interview that was a little whatever
that we're getting that stuff out now so
maybe as we get a little closer election
it could actually be about real that you
think do you think that's actually
possible it probably not right just know
I remember the last election like it we
were so talking about binders of women
and ridiculous things that no one really
cares about people like to focus on a
silly little things such as okay as long
as at the end of the day you're not
voting based off of that do you have a
binder of women let us know in the
comments right down below file this
under better late than never Pope
Francis commemorate the centenary of the
slaughter of Armenians calling the
massacre by the Ottoman Turks the first
genocide of the 20th century Francis
urged international organizations to
formally recognize the armenian genocide
in order to prevent such horrors from
repeating themselves Francis's comments
cause immediate outcry from Turkish
leaders the Turkish Foreign Minister
took to Twitter saying the Pope's
statement which is far from historic and
legal truth is unacceptable religious
positions are not places where unfounded
claims are made
featured mr. turkey went on to her call
its ambassadors for consultations and
some in the Vatican's and boy all right
so we're only a couple days from the
hundredth anniversary of the beginning
of the Armenian Genocide now obviously
the church had never acknowledged it
before many Western countries still
haven't acknowledged it but the reason I
want to do this story was because i
think this Pope is actually pretty
pretty good like this is a good Pope
he's done some stuff with about gay
people I know it's not perfect yet but
he's done a little something to take
these institutions are big it takes a
long time the dragon lair he's done a
lot of stuff with with homeless people
he's trying to do something good and
this strikes me as another good thing
that he's trying to acknowledge history
and and sort of move forward what do you
think about this Pope I do think he's
the coolest boat thus far yeah so I'm
with you on that but it is something
where um I do think ultimately the
Turkish ambassadors words really kind of
rung true for me when he said yeah when
he said that religious office is not the
place to take sides or push an agenda
especially when it's one that is talking
about the loss of lives when you make
one more important than the other
inadvertent might just by use of
language I can understand if I were
citizen of that country being taken
aback or feeling slighted right by that
but should we worry about the the Turks
feeling slighted if it's what if 1.5
million Armenians were killed here's the
thing I guess this goes to your point
about politics and related I don't think
they're bedfellows I just ultimately
they're not belt I do think for example
what you brought up oh he's done great
well not great things great things in
terms of the Catholic Church yeah it's
great terms right it's all slow let's
Costello and it's a huge step for that
kind of institution you're absolutely
right but I also think that at the end
of the day it's like when you start
politicking you end up creating more
dividing lines than you do uniting ones
sometimes because it's it's it's why
politicians really aren't necessarily
smart people they're just really good or
likable people right but then there you
can vote for them think that many ideas
may be stupid whereas a religious
organization as
one as prevalent as the Catholic Church
tamiya my my opinion yeah they need to
keep a self doing the church thing and
I'm gonna be over here doing my usual
I'll keep hanging out wafers yeah yeah
get on to drink juice and the little bit
of bread and I'ma be over here doing my
thing but I don't think that's I don't
think those are the two things that
should meet up right so now Jacqueline
if I know one thing about you it's that
you love religion and you love pokes so
how do you feel how do you feel about
this Pope in general somebody that's
trying to change yeah yeah I mean I
think this is one good thing that he's
done so I mean like he's done some good
things there's some things to do than
that I don't agree with but this is
definitely one of the more positive
things and the quote that you mentioned
I think yeah ideally that'd be great but
I feel like that's exactly what religion
is for it's a place where people do that
I think that's where comedy is where you
do that not not called that it's a 5 ATT
ideally that would be the case but it's
often not I don't it's good that the
Pope addressed this and I think it's
really shitty that the the Turkish
people they have about the people but
the leaders in the government it's like
they're trying to hide something that is
very blatantly obvious and they've been
trying to hide it and they try to act
like it's just a casualty of war and not
admit that it's a genocide right we
really are point five million people to
me this is the most underreported or
under acknowledged event that's happened
in the last literally hundred years why
it's great that the Pope actually call
them out on it and it's not letting them
just get away with it and shove it under
the rug like it's not a big deal yeah if
I will acknowledge that but i will also
acknowledge that there are so many more
countries of color especially in Africa
where there are genocides many genocides
on a daily if not weekly basis and then
go unacknowledged by media by the church
by other foreign powers I'm thinking if
you're gonna start driving join lines
and calling everybody I call everybody
out or shutting hello yeah I mean a lot
of times people are called out but the
difference is that they're trying to
hide it blatantly and this is the
anniversary so that's why I got brought
up it's not just like a random thing of
it no right right so is that the irony
here and that's when like the
geopolitics and religion I get it they
don't work together really and often
cause more
death and destruction than anything else
but for a lottery a lot of the Western
countries haven't acknowledged it
because they want to cozy up to Turkey
but now turkeys been sliding a little
bit away from the west so maybe some of
these countries will acknowledge it
which then could maybe lead to
acknowledging some of the other things
that you're talking about in Africa
maybe maybe I just at the end of the day
I think that when you create when
religion becomes more divisive than it
is something that unites yeah I mean I'm
not a particularly religious person yeah
but I mean let's not even get let's not
get into this but I still feel like
there's a there's a place for religion
and I think your point was great that
he's shining light on something and I
get that that's the positive aspect of
it it's bit something that's been
ignored or swept under the rug for a
long time so that's the positive aspect
of it but I don't I personally don't
feel as though religion is the place
yeah that is it hard for you to give
religion credit in in cases like this
even though you did clearly there but I
struggle with that like the idea of
something that has done so much [ __ ]
up [ __ ] in general I'm just talking
about general religion that when they do
these slow things like you're sort of a
little more okay with gays like I want
to be like wow that's great but like
they're still like hundreds of years
behind you know what I mean yeah I mean
that of course I agree with you but I
mean I don't always want to focus on all
the bad things and of course if I could
have my way I would try to get rid of
religion because I feel like it does
more harm than good and the good that it
does do can be done without religion but
whenever they do take steps like this of
course I'm going to be happy about it
because it overall has a positive effect
on everyone else and there are still so
many religious people that you know this
kind of thing is almost needed all right
well I don't know that we can solve
issues of genocide and religion right
here but let us know what you think in
the comments right now below I have a
420 first reason that we'd should be
legal the National Institute on Drug
Abuse has recognized a study proposing
marijuana may have a dramatic effect on
one of the most aggressive forms of
brain cancer according to the study by
state George's University of London when
use the fraidy ation extracts from whole
point marijuana increase the
cancer-killing effects of the radiation
the US Surgeon General claimed that in
the preliminary data for certain medical
conditions and symptoms marijuana can be
helpful alright so I want to be really
clear about this one point before we
start this which is that still as we say
now every time we do a weed video
marijuana is classified as a class 1
drug by the federal government that
means the government right now still
says the federal government still says
that it has no medicinal value that has
been disproven a bajillion times this is
just one study that it's been disproven
that it helps people with epilepsy and
seizures and cancer and AIDS and every
disease you can possibly think of people
take it to reduce stress they take it to
laugh it said well you know all those
jokes pine is this like a major major
failing of Obama i blame this on him
because even though everyone knows that
he's okay with weed why isn't he put he
has nothing to risk at this point why
doesn't he just get out there you know
he did that interview with Vice a couple
weeks ago and they asked him about and
they're like we know you're down with
lead and but what so why don't you do
and he basically was like well people
have other things to worry about which
is true but you're the president you can
do a lot of [ __ ] at once like why
doesn't he change this that's actually a
great point I mean I've never consumed
in my entire life like never this is you
say that every time we embrace it don't
know listen yes and this is a natural
high but I I've always believed in the
legalization of marijuana because I
think you can much more you could tax
the [ __ ] out of it yes look what's
happening in Colorado right now that's
money and put it back into the
infrastructures that are so underfunded
that's like it's a win-win people want
to get hat maybe you want to get some
money everybody's happy yeah it's like
the weed affected the world literally I
can't quote this exactly but I think in
the first month that Colorado legalized
marijuana they put four million extra
tax dollars into the public school
system
yeah you're gonna decrease the prison
population that's already a problem so
it's like there's like no downside so
what's going on so then so when the
politicians see something like this it
can shrink brain tumors I mean think
about that what that really means what
is the angle is this because the
pharmaceuticals are given them a lot of
money so they don't want weed I mean
Adam I said that's my best guess
honestly but it says I think you said
though you just found a reason before
then you said it it would reduce the
prison population yeah Prison is a
business prison this is big business
yeah prisons make so much money it's
terrifying yeah and if most of ink most
of the nonviolent crimes have to do with
drugs yeah and most of those are
probably I don't have any statistics
about me I'm probably weed they can't
lose a population they have to keep out
like I think it's a seventy two percent
occupancy well we also have we now have
for-profit private prisons which is
insane we actually have companies that
have an incentive to find people and put
them in jail for drug offenses I have
found the answer when he said that too I
don't understand why people are so
afraid of marijuana like it's there's
zero deaths reported as a result yeah of
marijuana and why is it in the same
category as other drugs like heroin yeah
heroin also LSD and ecstasy but heroin
yeah like what what the hell why well it
seems to me that it's because they
they're they're afraid that if they
legalize this and people realize that
has medicinal value it chills you out it
stops right p that people are gonna stop
popping pills and we are in a country of
people but this is all natural you're
telling me all natural you can have it
to you got a bottle that I'm such a dear
Donna I'm just saying Fritos out you're
gonna be in the same category pretty
soon as heroin how should Houston blows
I gotta say uh how soon will we be fully
legalized so it's going down we know
it's happening like a marriage right so
like we're gonna get there and this just
to call back to our Rampaul conversation
earlier where I said he's just doing
what's politically whatever like that's
what I think Obama's doing here but the
part that I don't get as I say
is that he has nothing to arrange thanks
Obama yeah like why not with a maybe
then is he waiting for the last month
like he's gonna break by the way guys
we'd wait for everybody yeah now what do
you think about the weed situation let
us know in the comments right down below
some people call them is some people
call them Isis some people call them I
sill I call them [ __ ] a 16 year old
school boy told the Daily Mail that he
saw Islamic state fighters playing
soccer with a severed human head inside
the Yarmouk refugee camp located just
six miles outside the Syrian capital
Damascus in december two thousand twelve
civil unrest transformed you are moved
from a thriving district into a combat
zone for anti and pro-government armies
before our MOOCs take over by Isis in
April close to eighteen thousand
refugees had been residing there only
about twenty five hundred of them or 500
families managed to escape in just a
week the terrorist group has killed
around 200 people alright so the Yarmouk
refugee camp it's been a disaster for a
long time they've basically been keeping
Palestinians in there giving them
virtually no rights the Syrian
government gives them pretty much
nothing and now Isis is rampaging
through there every time we do an Isis
story at this point between the headings
and burning people alive do you get
outraged anymore or do you even not even
outrage like I see this and it's just
like you see it on Twitter going by up
soccer with the human head up another
bike how desensitized to this stuff are
you in general I can't speak for anybody
else but i'm definitely not desensitized
but it is unfortunately not shocking
anymore yeah i'm not desensitized to the
horror of what this is so I mean it gave
me chills listening to that story again
but it's still one of those things where
you're like kind of think they would do
something that of a hora like think of
the worst possible thing yeah they're
probably yeah Isis is doing right now by
the way there's also history sadly
there's history of guys doing this with
heads al Qaeda was doing it a couple
years ago where's your descent we've
talked to Isis a lot when I've had you
on where's your desensitization level at
these days I feel like every time I read
something like this I have the same like
got like sickness feeling reaction I was
reading that article and there was a
part where they said that they were
cutting children's heads off in front of
their
like I mean that's a kind of thing that
just makes you sick yeah they have kids
literally doing that the headings now to
like what you said like you think of the
worst possible thing and they're
probably doing it so you know it's it's
already been clearly established that
Isis does not view the people who they
do these things to as human like they
just they have no moral sense for that
at all yeah so whenever they do these
things it's like they're doing it to an
inanimate object like they just do not
care so what do you guys think their
endgame is because we never talked about
this in the media we talked about what
should we bomb them should we how
horrible it is etc it said but what's
the hanging they can't behead everybody
you can't keep every woman covered head
to toe just with the solicitor eyes I
mean what do you think the end is I
think they're in game is to remove the
splits all together because I think
that's too much like that's way too much
flesh I don't know cuz I can't I can't
put my mind in that kind of mindset yeah
is that part of it though we can't like
I can't that's exactly I at least I
can't yeah them what the hell is what
are you doing like where is this how is
this going to end yeah and but my for me
it comes back back to what are we
waiting on like clearly these are like
kind of animals let's just call a spade
a spade what do we know so what should
we do what should what do you think was
we've talked about this before and I
always say I'm not for intervention in
general we've [ __ ] up so much in the
Middle East look at Iraq now it's
basically not a country anymore Syria's
pretty much not a country by all
standards so I'm not really for
intervention and yet we're watching some
truly horrific stuff happen if we could
have jumped in and stopped the Nazis
earlier if Twitter had existed back then
a YouTube and we would have seen what
was going on you know even in seen
footage of crematoriums river we
probably would have jumped in earlier
and we would have saved millions alive
so isn't it sort of incumbent on us to
do something I would like to do
something but at what point are you
crossing a line and and you know putting
yourself at risk or causing problems and
like I mean we already have a bad
reputation as the United States of going
places where we should be going and
staying in other countries for too long
but at the same time like you see
horrible things like this when you want
to jump in and help so even like myself
like I have a hard time like balancing
that in my own mind like oh I want to
help them well United States is
intervening all the time where they
shouldn't be or okay I
don't want to help them then what are
you doing so it's very so I think pretty
much everyone in the country feels that
way I think that's what it is we're
watching something horrible people are
thinking what you're saying what are we
waiting for and then the rest of the
half of the other the other half of the
brain is going well we please [ __ ] it up
so it's going to get worse but what do
you do with that you have to do
something though because I think that
whether or not monroe doctrine or
manifest destiny or whatever the united
states is a superpower we have the
ability to do so much more and yes we
[ __ ] up in the past we have [ __ ] up
in the past learn from our mistakes but
one of the things that we learn from is
like you said if anne frank was tweeting
instead of writing in her diary i would
like to hope that we would have saved
millions of people yeah rather than
waiting until pretty much the end to
jump in and do something like don't wait
until another million people are dead
and we've seen a million beheadings and
a million other obscene acts against
humanity and then you go finally we're
gonna come in i'm like that's a million
lives that could have been saved and
maybe that's why some of those countries
are in shambles cuz we wait long and
then go in and a whole bunch of people
die and there's nobody to be rebuild
anything i think this is a fascinating
philosophical argument which they're not
having on the news at all which is why i
want to talk about it here what are you
guys thinking do we have to do something
and when I say we yeah America but does
the world have to be saying are we
supposed to let it just just go to [ __ ]
what do we do about this let us know
what you think in the comments right
down below surely flying can't get more
comfortable it can and don't call me
shirley accidentally falling asleep on a
fellow passengers shoulder will be a
thing of the past that is if Boeing's
patent for a transport vehicle upright
sleep support system is approved
Boeing's invention dubbed cuddle chairs
by GeekWire will consist of backpack
like contraptions that passengers can
pull out from under their seats to rest
their head and chest on making
comfortable air travel accessible to all
alright so basically the future it's a
fine line between flying on an airplane
and [ __ ] a robot that seemed like
what it's going to be I want to do this
story because when we've done stuff
about planes I don't like to fly in
general I always every time I've ever
flown whether drugged or not I have a
moment thinking that that's it you know
I mean and it's all over and did i do
everything right and
all that but we've all had the people
sleeping on us we've all sat in the
middle all that so this is this is
pretty good this is a nice little
something you want to be strapped in
when when they get you would you like to
be strapped in to the seat you don't
want to be strapped in no that's scary
that does not look comfortable first and
foremost yeah like this is not a great
way to sleep I especially like when
you're traveling you know here to New
York or something six hours of this yeah
no um stop trying to squeeze more chairs
in and make all the seats tiny and then
you won't have to make a cuddle chair
right making sure that you have actually
comfortable so is about one wrong just
one right so is that really is that
really the thing here that they want to
squeeze every dime out of us so the
steets keep getting smaller and now
they're gonna strap us in I mean it
works into our favor too i mean the more
people that can fit on a plane the
cheaper tickets are gonna be yeah that's
already pretty expensive at us as it is
so i would trade that the money for any
sense of comfort anyways I can't you
yeah but I mean because six-hour flight
what even like leaning up against the
side of the window like fall into the
aisle or sleep on that somebody I I
don't know like I try to sometimes sleep
on the tray table which never really
works out but I curl up into a little
ball anyways and normally make it work a
little bit but I feel like that that
would i know i wouldn't mind like you
know yeah like I like put my knees up
and then kind of like I don't know that
be comfortable have you guys ever had
like one of those really bad experience
we've all had the kid crying kind of
thing or someone kick in your seat but
have you ever had something really bad
like someone's sleeping on you or like I
just I flew this week there was someone
within three rows that was farting
constantly you know and we're trapped in
a tin up there you know and I just
wanted to open the door a little just
let it out a lot that would be something
cuz I'm a friend Heather you know each
you did who blows up planes every time
not that way yeah I'm thinking okay
seriously like they need an invention
for that for her ass or all asses like
that like some sort of cushion that
would that would just absorb it yeah or
send it back into her that's weird um
have you ever had one of those just like
terrible flying just something yeah it
seems like I always get stuck in the
middle of people who liked like really
lino
were on their side of the arm chair so
that I'm like sitting in the middle kind
of like this like not sure like if I
want to eat something I kind of have to
like to like one of these types of
maneuvers yeah so yeah I wouldn't mind a
cuddle chair cuz then I could at least
like lean forward and avoid all of that
yeah but it seems kind of gross honestly
two at the same time cuz everybody's
like cuddling with the same thing yeah
and then you put your face in the hole
like even whenever I go to like if I
have to go to a chiropractor or like a
massage thing whatever you put your face
and it hits like I always kind of
hesitates it grosses me out especially
people sleep they drool so what are you
like that like I look after your faces
I'm sure there's gonna be some kind of
disposable no disposable not outright I
don't know anyway what do you think are
you comfortable on airlines as is do you
like the guys sleeping on your shoulder
have you ever met anyone that way let us
know in the comments right down below
2015 a space cappuccino mornings are
about to improve for the Italian
astronaut who's been suffering through
instant coffee at the International
Space Station an espresso machine is on
the spacex supply capsule that was
scheduled for launch earlier this week
especially designed italian-made
espresso maker is intended for
astronauts Samantha Christopher Eddie
who arrived on the space station in
November all right so I had to do this
story obviously because it combines two
of my favorite things space and coffee
if you were going up to space what would
be like the one thing that you
absolutely cuz i would need the coffee I
related to that so much as like if I
were up there that'd be the one thing I
would ask for I'll send me express oh
yes yeah absolutely I don't drink what
nice I don't you know what green coffee
you don't smoke weed told your badge oh
my god I don't really understand you
should be bottling that [ __ ] I will
patent pending guys yeah but if you were
going up to space well we only need a
man okay sorry that I should have
thought that not setting no I'll accept
that that's it that's it that's it oh it
has to be alive no that's that known did
me and I get I'm had it happen once not
again all right a live man that seems
that seems probably doable um would you
guys doable literally oh my god would
you guys go to space if you could I love
it I love the idea that even these
people that are doing this Mars thing
where it's only gonna be a one-way trip
and they know they're not coming home
like to me like I can I'm
get nauseous on a freaking merry go
around so i'm not going to space anytime
soon sounds awesome space is so cool and
i would love to see it maybe it just
scares me like honestly i haven't even
been on a cruise because i'm afraid of
going on a boat out into the middle of
an ocean and just feeling like you know
there's no safety oh I don't know
scariest part is cruise know the
scariest part of a cruise is the
all-you-can-eat buffet that's all yeah I
mean these people have you seen these
people at the buffet it's scary I
wouldn't worry about the water I'm just
I just am I guess you feel scared I've
CFC tonight yeah you're have seen a lot
of space movies too it's not revenue
yeah so I don't think so no space space
would you go you don't want to go to
space gravity I really liked it yeah
enough to have learned from her mistakes
don't go don't go don't go yeah what so
with the boats though why are we
searching that way you know James
Cameron he's building all this crazy
technology to go further below the water
than we ever have and I guess the next
couple avatars are gonna be underwater
but we have so much to explore that's on
this little blue dot just gloating
around like maybe we're not to go out
there maybe we just need to go down
there we pretty much sucked we're
sucking everything out of this ones
they're like let's look for a new planet
so that in 100 years when this one's
toast yeah we can move you think it's
gonna be a hundred years i'm looking at
like 40 I was being optimistic I told
you laughing smiley yeah we're exploring
down there why don't we do more of that
like I feel like that's just like if you
were if an explorer was like yes I'm
gonna go down to the depths of the
Pacific people would be like come on
dude this is in nineteen twenty I still
think it'd be cool I mean what anything
that's unknown should be explored
anything that's unknown should be
explored I think that's a fine ending so
I want to thank Shawna and Jacqueline
I'm gonna let you guys pimp yourselves
out you're used to talking two cameras
oh who the hell are you and what are you
doing Shana Malcolm actress funny chick
youtube personality Oh turtley
optimistic guerlain you were mad they
find me at youtube.com slash hey Sean in
case you haven't been paying attention
or on Twitter which my name's Shauna
Malcolm and Instagram is the same Shana
Malcolm that's professional branding
Jacqueline how do these good people find
you professional branding this is
Jacqueline Glen everywhere youtube com
Glenn Glenn Instagram same thing Twitter
same thing Facebook same thing so find
me if you've learned anything this week
it's that branding is the most important
thing there is anyway thanks for
watching guys we will do it again next
week